foreign
this this might be the worst and I mean
this sincerely
what Media Matters has been trying to do
to Tucker has been one of the [__]
worst like so hilarious too because it's
just backfiring
I was actually listening to our good
friend Dan bongino
uh I was listening to his show yet and
honestly was listening to it yesterday
because I was like I remember this in a
Tucker I'm like what am I gonna listen
to on the way home from the gym so just
put like punchino on and he would
literally start the show just laughing
he goes yo I've never seen like I mean
I've been a newspapers for a long time
and I'm not even saying this because you
know I like Tucker or I'm defending fox
or anything it's like whatever Media
Matters is just like the worst his piece
I've ever seen it goes you humanized
sucker and I was like you're right it's
exactly they completely completely
humanize them everybody who has watched
these clips is like well Tucker's kind
of cool so this particular specifically
the [__] it will do it live yeah that
was my favorite everyone loves that clip
because he's laze giggling and everybody
he's like this guy rules
um there yeah they're really this is the
weirdest like smear campaign I've ever
seen you know
um so this is um
this is one of the newer this is another
leak these are the crazy leaks brother
Tucker's done after this one okay so
this is him uh talking about when he was
deposition for the Dominion thing
um okay
well that was a week I'll say
[Music]
holy [__]
ten hours
that slimy little [__] sitting
across from me oh you're the best
you're trying to make me feel
you're trying to make me not like that
that's hilarious in any context okay so
so far you've showed me that Tucker has
no respect for authority and he treats
his employees very well I'm sorry but
yeah what wow so Tucker reserves all of
his contempt for those in power and
those of them pose their will on people
what a piece of garbage garbage after 10
hours of a deposition still comes in and
laughs jokingly with his [__] staff
you know merch what a piece of garbage
what
a [__] like what a what a just what a
hunk of [__] this guy is you know what's
funny
Don Lemon and Tucker if you would have
filmed Don Lemon like all fair there
were leaks of him if they would have got
him on the bird
what would have happened was it would
have been like this oh bro look at it
look how she's dressed oh my God she
thinks she's hot being catty you know
that sort of being oh of course oh my
God she thinks she's hot oh my God and
then him taking his he's a the problem
is he was relatable and by the way
anybody anybody who has ever been to a
debit I've been to a deposition anyone
who's ever been to like a deposition and
you're sitting there wasting your time
in a cold conference room usually you
know freezing your ass off with shitty
powdered creamer and old coffee
somehow they have good coffee
yeah but you don't get good coffee no
because yeah they'll show up with coffee
like they got from Duncan or like from
Starbucks exactly because they knew
because they worked there and they know
the coffee [__] and you're just like you
said you're trying to mix that powdered
cream and it never mixes right
lukewarm you're like this just sucks man
right so anyway they're like so uh Royce
in 2016
um on on June 23rd could you go over
with me that day and what you did no no
I have no [__] idea I don't remember
any of this uh well it's under penalty
perjury okay no I get it but like I
don't remember any of this we're going
to prison so well that was a week I'll
say
[Music]
holy [__]
ten hours
that slimy little [__] sitting
across oh you're the best I wasn't
talking about you I wasn't talking about
you it's just the opposition
no I'm not what do you mean because
you've never been misaffirmed in your
life
yeah
he's just a looks like a pleasure to
work with
that was really good you know the sperm
in your life I noticed the other side of
this too right all they have is this
Abby grossberg lady who's never met him
right who admitted she never met the guy
and she's suing him but they haven't
found any regular employees to come out
against him with anything
it really is that one human being has
come out and been like this [__] guy
was the worst the worst guy [__] ever
yes this is the opposite no he's giving
me a complex no I'm not what do you mean
because you've never been this affirmed
in your life
I bet thank you Alex have a happy
weekend
Gmail on
the amount oh my God Jen Jesus Christ I
like Alex Jones too but not everything
is a [__] it's like I get so frustrated
man because like all these conspiracy
stuff like it just blows my mind like
here's a perfect example I've been
watching two of my child Alex Jones
Tucker's dad being a CIA plus a CIA
agent this being leaked seems too
convenient to me okay I'm sorry walk me
through
what what the triple secret reverses
with this
that this what's the cia's end game to
make Tucker look good for what reason
yeah also like oh my God I'm so sick of
this and by the way Alex and Tucker are
friends
also dumbass no offense but dumbass
don't be a dumbass dumbass yeah
it's pronounced Don boss oh I saw it um
well stop being a dumb boss you dumbass
no it's pronounced Russia yeah no but uh
but no it's it's [__] yeah by the way
it was a tweet the other day it was like
a Russian warplanes uh uh uh drop uh you
know whatever drop bombs on a Russian
city of 400 000 and I just retweeted it
I'm like yeah it's called Kev yeah
um
no like this whole like black pill
trying to act what you know God I don't
know what what are they trying to like
like Roy said what's the double triple
reverse card here yeah like they're
already like dumping poison into your
rivers and [__] your kids like how
how much worse do you think it's getting
what's this what's the Tucker what's the
[__] get out of here what's the play
here they literally had an entire Island
where they just [__] kids
the NSA was illegally tapping Tucker's
phone like I know he is illegally
terrible oh my God yes yes the company
there's a bunch of yes there's a bunch
of psyops there's a bunch of people but
not every single thing is one
you know yeah that sounds like something
that somebody running a psyop would say
take your they live glasses off one time
just to [__] notice that there's one
by the way so what we're saying is
there's one person in mainstream media
who's fighting against all of it and
even that's faking gay all of it's
faking gay I don't care shy FBI sir this
is a this is a Wawa I I just asked for
your name for your order
by the way I turned to a guy last night
at the bar who literally was dressed
just like a Fed yeah and just to be
funny I turned to him and I was like hey
what's up so are you the FED that was
assigned to follow me and the guy got so
uncomfortable that I think he was
legitimately a Fed oh really yeah like I
had nothing to do with me right like I
don't think he was actually following me
I'm not getting gang stuck right the guy
had like the cargo shorts he had the Hat
he had the polo shirt and he wasn't a
golfer he was like a younger fit guy
dressed like an old golfer yeah she's
sitting there hanging out talking to a
bartender I know I was having a drink
and I don't know where I just turned to
him okay are you the fed that's assigned
to me I think I just started drinking
his beer like Tony Khan at the media
scrum
and then he was just laughing and stuff
like awkwardly and I'm like wow I was
[__] kidding but Jesus
I didn't for fed before I I am 100 yeah
and I really did and I don't know if
maybe I just scared the guy like maybe
he thought I was [__] nuts you know
like and he was just nerving it laughing
nervously but he had the Little Apple
watch and everything hey uh hey hey
Virgie maybe like turn off uTorrent or
whatever's bogging down your internet
you gotta break it up a little bit
yeah you sound like chicken bean yeah
God damn it it was so unhealthy the hate
thank you Teresa the hate that I felt
for that I mean thank you I I how did
you not I well I never feel that way you
know because I don't put myself I don't
want to feel that way
that is totally bad for you to feel that
way what a piece of [__] huh but that
guy he
triggered the [__] out of me
don't understand why all these clips of
him being sincere are supposed to hurt
him
look the only way you take Tucker out is
if you catch him being dishonest right
or not practice lying or whatever but
none of these are that but these are
moments of literal like him speaking
truthfully and being like you know I
normally try not to like I try not to
think that way but I [__] hated that
guy and by the way we've all felt that
way yeah
where are you now where do you live
the amount of times first of all [__]
you on my lips
for the fastest it's like
it was unbelievable
suggesting that I was that I was
cheating on my taxes
so what what's where you've done us up
where are you now if you're on a home
there
I was like no I do not I don't know my
name
this is like yeah this is what it feels
like and then hold on get ready
you ready you ready they got him he's
sexist did you see this one he's a
sexist piece of [__] you ready what a
sexist piece of [__] to ask you a
question you don't have to answer it's
personal I'm not speaking of you but
more in general of ladies when they go
to the ladies room and part of their
noses is there actually nose powdering
going on
sometimes oh
I like the sound of that
[Laughter]
it's pretty funny actually I mean again
what's the problem here I don't see the
it's they really are so desperate to
make something out of nothing and nobody
like again we talked about this the
other day even the people that don't
like Tucker are like okay but what's the
what's the show yeah exactly what's the
get here it's like I want a Barry Tucker
right next to you but like what come on
man we got to get something better than
man that [__] Warrior was a real
[__] oh man get him who doesn't
think lawyers are [__]
this is Thomas lipstick
the pillow fights ever break out you
don't have to not in the bed okay never
break out no not in the bathroom that's
pretty funny that'd be more a dorm
activity
so you are such a good sport such a good
person thank you
[Music]
oh thank you Media Matters for bleeping
her name out that's such a good sport
thank you God he's again man I just
couldn't imagine working for this
[__] piece what a piece of garbage
[__] [__] and it's so I love the
timing of this because these leaks came
out with the Crowder leagues yeah so
it's such an amazing it's like of all
times it's it's beautiful the contrast
the [__] contrast
you know you do but you do not see the
uh you guys see the text message you
guys the text message they're ringing
about oh that's a good one you want to
read it yeah I'll read it right quick
grab it okay check this out you ready
he's done Tucker Carlson on January 7th
2021 a couple of weeks ago I was
watching video of people fighting on the
street in Washington a group of trump
guys surrounded an antifa kid started
pounding the living [__] out of him it
was three against one at least uh
jumping a guy like that is dishonorable
obviously it's not how white men fight
yes suddenly I found myself rooting for
the mob against the man hoping they'd
hit him harder kill him I really wanted
him to hurt the kid I could taste it
somewhere deep in my brain an alarm went
off this isn't good for me I'm becoming
something I don't want to be the antifa
creep as a human being much as I despise
what he says and does much as I'm sure
I'd hate him personally if I knew him I
shouldn't glowed over his suffering I
should be bothered by it I should
remember that somewhere somebody
probably loves this kid and would be
crushed if he was killed if I don't care
about those things if I reduce people to
their politics how am I better than he
is now out of that entire text that what
the only thing we're talking about is
that's not how white men fight I know of
course but
again to be fair it's not healthy he's
right but he's right but he's 100 right
I mean and forget that it's like so what
you saw here was a candid moment of a
text message to his producer by the way
that the people thought that he didn't
think anybody was going to see
showing what that he's a human with
feelings that does he doesn't want to
let the darkness take over stuff that
pretty much every human being struggles
with
what a piece of crap
the problem is all these people are such
sociopaths like all these media matter
peoples are such [__] sociopaths and
all this [__] [__] that they they
won't they they honestly lack human
empathy and emotion right everything to
them is a political game everything to
them is a [__] everything to them is
war everything to them is you know or
everything's to show to these [__]
people right so when somebody shows
genuine Humanity they're like what is
this that can't be real no sometimes
people actually aren't [__] you know
sometimes no you do but you do not
deserve that and I mean it with great
affection I got you man
yes ma'am sorry let me tune in
[Music]
there you go those are the new leaks for
today
and uh how's he gonna [__] survive
this I wonder if his wife's gonna leave
him I mean yeah you would think that his
wife will leave him
[__] watch it
uh
uh it's it's it's
um in any other comments for this like
all the comments are just everybody
being like
thank you sir for such uplifting content
Tucker jokes with a team member and then
tells her what a good person she is
that's what happened there joke with a
team member and told her what a good
person she was it's like you said just
any basic human interaction they just
don't know what to do that's not how
people are supposed to be no believe it
or not there was a time that's how most
people tried to be